[音楽]
[拍手]
皆さんこんにちは広島大学のゆけです
今日はですね人は人を幸せにするために
生まれてくるという私の新年に近いものな
んですけどその話をしようと思います
皆さん
皆さんのフィロソフィーって何ですか私の
フィロソフィーはですね
絶望してる人々を救いたいと考えています
それを実現するためには全部で3つの
エンジンを指そうとします
それは一つはですねまあ思いついたらすぐ
に実行するもう一つまあ難しいことは考え
ず
楽天的な姿勢で臨む3番目は失敗すること
を恐れない
失敗の数が多いほど
成功する可能性が高くなるというふうに
考えるということです
簡単に言うとですねまあ成功するまでやれ
ば
必ず失敗しないわけですねでこういう考え
方になるのにやはり長い時間かかって
急にできるようになったわけではありませ
んこれまでの経験から作り上げた人生観が
私のプロフィールを作るわけですねで
これまでどういうことをしてきたかそのま
あ説明を簡単に私の人生を話をさせて
いただきます私はですね
奨学金をもらって
留学する機会をいただきました
ちょうど29歳の時ですね最初の渡ったの
がシアトルですねでこのシアトルに渡って
数日で気づいたんですがこれまでの人生を
リセットできるということに気づいたわけ
ですこれはまだ私の人生は
日本でこれまで暮らしてきててあまり自分
には納得する人生ではなかったそれが
リセットできたそれでこの
留学の間に何をすればいいのかをもう必死
で考えるわけですねこれシェラトンの摩天
楼の中をですねダウンタウンですがこの
フリーウェイをですねお前版のように9時
から12までぶっ飛ばすんですね
なぜか知らないけどアメリカのFMを聞き
ながらぶっ飛ばす
毎日考えて
ぶっ飛ばすんですね
まあその先にベリビューっていうところが
あって
マリナーズの
例のイチローが住んでたとこあるんです
けどそこまでこう来てますね
ぶっ飛ばして何を考えてたか自分のよく
覚えてないですけどとにかく
必死で何かを考えつこうとするでこれ私が
留学してた大学のこれ図書館なんですけど
ほとんどもハリーポッター状態ですね
365日24時間空いてるんですけど私は
ほとんど手前の方で
あのずっと毎朝6時から勉強会があって
それが毎晩ぶっ飛ばすんでもう眠くてです
ねここでちょっと図書館で机抱えて寝てた
んだよねで私の教授がですねもうハリー
ポッター状態なんであの法規に乗って飛ん
でくるんですよそういう夢を見るのね私
あの福岡出身なんで私の教授が言うんです
で
なんば人とね
小顔のとこで寝とってもうちょっと真面目
にやりにさえ言われてでもうちょっと僕も
考えを変えてですね勉強しないといけない
なと気づいたことがありますで
渡ってとシアトルから次にですねまあ
カナダの
ユニバーサルバーターという大学に留学を
しました大学のキャンパスは非常に広いん
ですが私はここのキャンパスにいて非常に
勉強になる出会いがあったんですねそれは
あのカナダの冒険者のトレーニングセン
ターっていうところに行ってこの1990
年の建物なんですが
午前中はスポーツクリニックで働きをして
その後だいたい6時から10時までずっと
ボランティアでこの冒険者トレーニング
センターに行ってましたそうするとですね
まあいろんな
難民が来るんですね
その難民っていうのは
ベルリンの壁が壊れてから何十年も経って
てもやっぱりたくさん難民が出てるんです
でロシアもウクライナもポーランドも
チェコ人もバルト人も皆さん国籍の違いは
なくて
難民同士が助け合って生活をしてるんです
ねみんな貧乏なんですよでもみんな
支え合ってるこれが私にとって非常に決定
的に大きい
インプレッションというかこれからやりた
いっていうことにつながってると思って
おりますで私大学に留学してて
研究してたんですけどTP
マーチンと知り合うことができましたこれ
その時の私の写真ですけど今と比べて
すごい痩せてるでしょ
もうねで毎朝Goodmorningって
言ってTakemetoNASAって言う
んですねでこのTPマーティンはNASA
の研究者だったで
毎朝言うんですよTakemeto
notherとそうするとですねある日
本当にジョンソンスペースセンターに連れ
て行ってくれたんですねもうやっぱり出会
いっていうのはすごく大切で
誠意を持ってお願いしてるとまあこんな
ことが叶うんだなと思いましたでこの
ジョンソンスペースセンターで研究をして
きたわけですね
まあスペースシャトルなんですけど
スペースシャトル打ち上げるとですね
1000分の1g10のマイナス30Gの
環境になります皆さん
打ち上げてどれくらいの時間で10の
10の-30gになるかご存知ですか
みんな頭
会社が出ますが6分30秒でも広くなん
ですねだから35億年の生命の歴史の中で
それがですね10分足らずでこの
無重力の
環境に適応しないといけないのでまあ名前
宇宙的を症候群っていうそういう症候群に
なるわけですね私のスーパーバイズの
TPOマーチンはこの
筋萎縮を
研究してたわけですでこの筋萎縮の環境は
細胞がですね
成熟しない
未文化な状態になっちゃうので
菌がだんだん細くなるということが研究で
分かったですね
皆さんシャトルをどうやって運ぶかご存知
ですか
もうこうやってですね
ジャンボジェットの上に乗っけて運ぶん
ですねまあ普通
列車とか
船で運ぶんじゃなくて
ジャンボの上でこうやって運ぶと私これ見
たときも抜かれてコーヒー飲んでたんです
けど私のネクタイが
コーヒーなんか使ってたというぐらいの
もんですがまあ非常にアメリカ的ですねで
日本に帰るとシャトルがないんですねで
まあ普通パラボリックフライトとか
落下実験あるんですがそれでやっても10
秒足らずなんですね私たち動物実験とか
細胞培養すると数時間から1日以上いると
いうことで
重力制御装置というものを開発をしました
これはですね重力ベクトル時間軸で分散し
てでこれ時間平均でゼロに近づくという
装置でこれを開発しましたら最初は
NASAが導入をしてくれました
でこういう道具を使ってですね私たちは
再生医療で
脳卒中の患者さんを救いたいという風に
考えています
現在脳卒中の患者さんは130万人
いらっしゃいますで今発症者はですねまあ
年間30万人日本は2分に1人でそれが
世界はですね2秒にしてるようになる一般
的な病気なんですね皆さんどの患者さんも
脳卒中になる前の体に戻りたいというのが
本当の希望なんですねでも現代医学で管理
できない疾患に対して可能な限り感じ
できる医療の一部のなりたいということで
そのためにはリハビリの質を上げて
幹細胞の質を上げるということが重要だと
考えています
で最初に再生のお話ですね私たちは今
ヒューマンプロジェクトというものを広島
大学で行っています私たちは幹細胞を作る
ことができますでリハビリができるそれ
からロボットを作ることができるんですね
それをですね
脳の障害なので
脳のマッピング技術で評価をするという
ことをしています
でこの三位一体というんですが細胞培養が
できてリハビリができてロボットができる
全部一人の人間がわかるってことが重要な
んですねその理由はですね非常にうまく
いった時にどこが聞いてるのか
うまく治らない時にどこが悪いのかって
いうことを考えることができ
るっていうのは全てできる必要があるわけ
ですね私たちはこのサミットができるのは
多分世界で私だけだだけだという風に考え
ていますで一応世界初の当該来の関与系幹
細胞を使った再生医療を解消しましたまあ
これ脳が貼れるとですね
脳が不十分になるので
腫れると外減圧という手術をしてそれから
細胞を体外で増やして
静脈野球で入れるというプロジェクトで
ございます
1%しかない細胞をいかにクオリティを
増やしたかってのは非常に難しくてそれで
これまで私がNASAでやってきた技術が
使えるわけですねで今無重力の環境で培養
して高品質な細胞培養の技術というものを
確立をしましてこれを今今年からですね
まあ再生医療で実用化して
活用してるっていう状況でございます
であとリハビリのロボットの話なんですが
私たちはその幹細胞を使った再生医療です
けど最初は
根治療法だから細胞さえあれば治るって
思われてたんですね20年前ところが
臨床研究が始まるに従ってリハビリの事業
性が高まってまいりましたそれでまあ通常
のリハビリじゃなくて違うリハビリやり
たいと思ってロボットの開発に入ったわけ
ですでこの歩行補助装置というものを8
年間かかって作りました
これ足首だけを
補助するもので重量が非常に軽くて済む
わけですねでコンパクトでどこでも持って
いけるっていうのが利点ですもう一つは
このタブレットでタッチパネルで
コントロールできるのでリモートの手動が
できるというのがこのロボットの大きな
特徴ですね
このロボットはずっとつけておく必要が
ないんですねです正しい方向を体に覚え
させるものでリハビリ前につま先が光って
くって引っかかってた人がまあだいたい
20分
週に3回から4回乗って2週間経つとどう
やって歩けばいいのかっていうことを学習
して勉強してくれるんですね患者さんが
そうすると踵からつけるようになるとこう
いうロボットを開発をしました
で私たちの患者さんをちょっと狂乱します
この患者さん脳出血の患者さんで来られた
時は車椅子だったんですねで
リハビリを6ヶ月受けられたんですが総合
をつけて
杖を使って歩いていらっしゃるでも日常
生活はもうこれじゃあ外に出れないから車
椅子ですで再生医療を受けられましたそう
すると
チェーンもいらない装具もいらない不安定
ではないので車いすではないんですが
遠くから見るとやはり
墜落高校って言うんですけど
異常方向なんですね
膝が曲がらないこうドーンドーンという
墜落方向それで私たちのところに来られて
ロボットを使ったリハビロすると
膝が曲がって蹴れるんですねで学習したら
外せるので1ヶ月経つと1ヶ月の違いだけ
ですねスピードも非常に上がって歩ける
ようになるとこの監査員は何をしてる
かっていうと
走ってらっしゃいますね2年前に
クリスマスだった人が今ホノルルマラソン
にエントリーできるぐらい回復をされて今
走ってらっしゃる人生を変えることが
できるんですね私たちはこういう技術を
持ってて再生医療とロボット
リハビリテーションをプロトコールが一番
大切なんですけどそれを組み合わせると
どこでも同じような結果を得ることができ
ますこの
患者さんもう一人紹介したんですけど入院
の時はですね車椅子で来られましたこの
患者さん歩けるようになったんですけど
それ以上に大きな勉強させていただいた
患者さんですねちょっと聞いてください
とかっていうことだったんですけど1ヶ月
2ヶ月から
徐々に骨盤が出てきて
十分喋れるようにはなりました全体では6
回
奥さんと会話をしています
ラブラブですねそうですね入院された時は
一切喋れなかった再生とリハビリで回復
するに従って話ができるようになりまして
6ヶ月は自分の家にお電話されるんですね
で最初奥さんと話すことがなかったんだ
けどもしゃべれる喜びがあって
毎日のように6回も喋られるわけですね
電話されて歩けることも大切なんですけど
生活を豊かにするためのQOLとは何かと
いうのをこの換算から考えさせていただい
たわけですねこの再生医療と
ロボットリアビリテーションこれ三位一体
を一つにしてやることでこれから
絶望した人々を救う私のフィロソフィーに
つながる技術が確立をしましたで
ウクライナの話ですね
まあ同じ人間として何かをしたいと考えて
いますまあ子供の
被害が非常に多いんですねで東部外相って
いうのは
脳卒中の患者さんと全く同じ症状ですね
私たちが知ってる中で2万人の関西
いらっしゃるもう絶望のどん底に
いらっしゃるわけですねでその
患者さんたちを救うためにですねまあ実際
ジョージアと国の方から
依頼があってスタートしたプロジェクト
です
[音楽]
ヶ月かかってですね
チームをやっと作り上げたんですねで実際
ウクライナの人道支援で再生医療と
リハビリテーションプログラムということ
をやってまして再生医療とリハビリと
ロボット
これは日本が誇る最新の技術ですねでこれ
を使って再生医療を
ジョージアという国なんですがウクライナ
の人々を救いたいと考えています
でもう
そうですねもう20万人
募集はもう全部含めて30万人ですね子供
の被害者が非常に多いもう戦争そのもの
ですねやめる必要があるんじゃないかなと
考えております
先ほどお話をしましたがこれ私の哲学で3
つのエンジンを使ってまあこれまでやって
きたことですがまあ成功するまで必ず失敗
しないまあぜひやり遂げてみたいなと思っ
ています
まあこれ最後のスライドですがこの
E=mc2というこれ相対性理論なんです
がこれを考えついた実はアインシュタイン
が
原子爆弾の理論的根拠になるんだという
ことで自分をですね最後本当に悔やんで
いろんな平和活動しましたその時にこの
アインシュタインが最後に残した言葉です
人は人を幸せにするために生まれてくる
これ私の
哲学でもあるんですが聞いていただきます
この技術で絶望した人を救いたいこれは私
のフィロソフィーですまあ最後の質問です
ね
皆さんのフィロソフィーとは何でしょうか
どうもご清聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]